ya tenemos las herramientas para
multiplicar cualquier cantidad entonces
vamos a bueno voy a hacer en este vídeo
un montón de ejemplos digamos que
tenemos el número 32 entonces el número
32 lo voy a multiplicar por por el
número 18 ajá entonces vamos a hacer
esto a 8 por 2 es igual a 16 ahora lo
voy a hacer mentalmente no voy a
escribir acá por un lado las
multiplicaciones porque no siempre
tenemos espacio entonces 8 por 2 es
igual a 16 pongo el 6 aquí llevamos 1
entonces 8 por 3 es igual a 24 y 24 más
uno es igual a 25
por lo tanto 8 por 32 es igual a 256 y
ahora vamos a multiplicar por este 1 que
en realidad es un 10 entonces 1 por 2 es
igual a 2 aunque debes tener aquí
cuidado ten cuidado aquí porque tal vez
tú quieras poner aquí abajo el 2 pero
recuerda que este no es un no es un 1 no
puedes poner aquí el 2 este no es un 1
es un 10 así que para recordar eso
ponemos simplemente un cero
y ahora 10 por 2 es igual a 20 o puedes
simplemente decir 1 por 2 es igual a 2
ahora como pusimos el 0 aquí obtenemos
20 de todos modos jajaja y ahora 1 por 3
vamos a deshacernos de esto que
escribimos antes esto no nos sirve
ahorita entonces 1 por 3 es igual a 3 y
no hay nada que sumar aquí entonces
simplemente ponemos el 3
así que obtenemos 10 por 32 es igual a
320 este este uno es un 10 porque 10 más
8 es igual a 18 ahora simplemente
sumamos estos valores 6 + 0 es igual a 6
52 es igual a 7 y 23 es igual a 5 porque
llegamos
seguimos hagamos otro ejemplo hagamos
que te parecen 99 por 88 esto nos va a
dar un número bastante grande entonces
ok
8 por 9 es igual a 72 llevamos 7
y otra vez a 8 x 9 es igual a 72 7 es
igual a 79 pongo el 79 aquí porque ya no
tenemos más dígitos ahora voy a borrar
voy a borrar eso y multiplicamos por
este 8 entonces este no es un 8 es un 80
es en un lugar de las escenas entonces
pongo un cero aquí y multiplicamos 8 por
9 es igual a 72 llevamos 7 8 por 9 es
igual a 72 más 7 es igual a 79 ahora
sumamos 2 + 0 es igual a 29 más dos es
igual a 11 llevamos 171 es igual a 8 más
9 es igual a 17 y 71 es igual a 8
la respuesta es 8.712 y ya terminamos
hagamos otro ejemplo entonces seguimos
qué te parece si multiplicamos 53 x
78 78 entonces vamos a multiplicar este
8 primero 8 por 53 entonces 8 por 3 es
igual a
a 24 llevamos 28 por 5 es igual a 40 más
dos es igual a 42 a hunt 42 ahora
multiplicamos por este 7 este 7 recuerda
que es un 70 por que es 70 + 8 es igual
a 78 así que pongo un cero aquí
y primero voy a voy a borrar esto para
no confundirnos entonces multiplicamos 7
por 3 es igual a 21 llevamos 2 7 por 5
es igual a 35 2 es igual a 37 entonces
37 ella ahora vamos a sumar 40 es igual
a 42 más uno es igual a 34 7 es igual a
11 llevamos uno entonces 3 más uno es
igual a 4 y la respuesta es 4.134 ahora
hagamos hagamos un ejemplo un poco más
un poco más complicado digamos que tengo
796 x x 58 ajá entonces x 58 primero voy
a multiplicar este 8 por 796 entonces
este 8 primero 8 por 6 es igual a 48
baja 8 por 6 es igual a 48 con 18 aquí
llevamos 48 por 9 es igual a 72 + 4 es
igual a 76 ahora 8 por 7 es igual a 56 7
es igual a 63
y tal vez seguro cometer algún error si
yo por ahí es pero si es que lo comento
lo veas entonces aquí es 63 y ahora
vamos a multiplicar por este 5 va a
multiplicar a todos los dígitos de 796
ahora este 5 esté en el lugar de las
decenas entonces es un 50 voy a poner un
cero un cero aquí no olvidemos poner el
cero aquí y multiplicamos 5 por 6 es
igual a 30 0 y llevamos 35 por 9 es
igual a 45 más 3 es igual a 48 5 por 7
es igual a 35 4 es igual a 39
a 39 y ya sumamos entonces 80 es igual a
86 +0 es igual a 63 más 8 es igual a 11
pongo 1 aquí y llevamos 11 más 6 es
igual a 7 + 9 es igual a 16 y uno más 3
es igual a 4 la respuesta de 796 por 58
es igual a 46 mil 168 y de hecho se ve
que sí porque 796 es casi 800 y 800 es
casi 1000 si multiplicamos 1000 por 58
obtendríamos 58 mil pero estamos
multiplicando 58 por algo que es menor
que 1000 entonces el resultado está en
ese intervalo porque bueno 46 miles es
menor que 58 mil entonces está en ese
intervalo ahora hagamos otro ejemplo
donde voy a poner números bastante
grandes pero no te asustes estará estará
sencillo es lo mismo hagamos en este
caso 523 x
qué te parece de 798 entonces es el
mismo procedimiento aplica a cualquier
cantidad de dígitos multiplicado por
cualquier cantidad de dígitos verás que
hay un patrón y es lo mismo simplemente
multiplicas a cada uno de ellos por los
dígitos que están arriba ahora iniciamos
con esto vamos a multiplicar el 8
multiplica a cada uno de los dígitos en
523 entonces 8 por 3 es igual a 24
llevamos 2 8 por 2 es igual a 16 más 2
que llevamos es igual a 18 entonces
llevamos 1 ahora 8 por 5 es igual a 40
más uno es igual a 41
por lo tanto 8 por 523 es igual a 4
1.184 y ahora multiplicamos por el 90 y
por el 700 entonces primero sigue el 90
entonces pongo un 0 aquí abajo porque
estamos multiplicando por 90 y voy a
borrar esto para no equivocarnos y no
confundirnos multiplicamos
por 3 es igual a 27 llevamos 29 por 2 es
igual a 18 más 2 es igual a 20
entonces pongo un cero aquí y llevamos 2
9 por 5 es igual a 45 más 2 que llevamos
es igual a 47 entonces pongo un 47 acá
abajo porque ya no tenemos más dígitos
uy no quise escribir así de grueso así
está mejor 47 entonces si lo hice bien
dejarán déjame aseguro porque a ver
vamos a multiplicar 9 por 3 es igual a
27 llevamos 2 y 9 por 2 es igual a 18
sumamos 26 20 ok entonces 9 por 5 es
igual a 45 más 2 es igual a 47 si hay
que hay que asegurarnos siempre de no
cometer errores y si los cometemos pues
hay que asegurarnos entonces lo que
sigue vamos a multiplicar 700 por 523
cuando multiplicamos por 8 simplemente
multiplicamos cuando multiplicamos por
90 puse un cero aquí ahora qué
700 voy a poner dos ceros y voy a borrar
esto de acá arriba porque nos puede
confundir ahora ya multiplicamos 7 por 3
es igual a 21 llevamos 2 7 por 2 es
igual a 14 más 2 que llevamos es igual a
7 x 5 es igual a 35 1 es igual a 36
entonces aquí va 36 y ya multiplicamos
hablo perdón sumamos si sumamos entonces
ya multiplicamos ahora vamos a sumar 400
es igual a 48 70 es igual a 15 111 es
igual a 34 76 es igual a 17 y 41 es
igual a 56 es igual a 11 3 más uno es
igual a 4 por lo tanto 523 por 798 es
igual a 417 mil 354 y ha llegado el
momento de la verdad del momento que
todos estábamos esperando calculadora al
ataque vamos a ver si estamos en lo
correcto
523 por 798
esto es igual a ahí lo tienes perfecto
entonces es igual a 417 mil 354 pero
nosotros lo hicimos sin la calculadora
lo cual es lo importante somos valientes